c'est bien connu un cochon ça dévore et
ça ne connaît pas les jours fériés
florent le prêtre passe son nouvel an
comme ça au milieu de ces bêtes pour cet
agriculteur
pas de repos même dans les lendemains
difficiles
même si nous on fait la fête eux il leur
faut leur nourriture
c'est comme nous voilà on boit un café
on mange une tarte et nous ou de
tartines en fonction voilà messieurs
atteindre juste le café c'était
suffisant il me dit il
et à marguerittes après les réveillons
arrosée ce sont les veaux qui réclame à
boire fait quand même bon adulé une
tâche quotidienne qui remet les idées au
clair matin et soir tous les jours de
l'année
il s'appelle nous arrivait de prendre
des vacances mais nous on est plusieurs
à travailler sur neuf rotations mais
aujourd'hui j'atteins le tour de garde
qui tombe c'est aussi un avantage de là
plusieurs mais aujourd'hui il ne peut
compter que sur lui et sur la
technologie
avec ce robot par exemple plus besoin de
traire à la main le travail d'astreinte
est diminué par contre il faut toujours
surveiller le troupeau faire boire les
veaux nourrir les animaux
et puis le métier de lait des éleveurs
c'est aussi de la surveillance
l'observation notre éleveur ne compte
pas ses heures
aimer son métier c'est déjà l'assurance
de passer une très bonne année